i ragazzi sono contentissimo di fare
questo video perché è una cosa nella
quale io credo fermamente e quindi si
vede tutta la mia passione quando
racconto questa cosa mi amici che era un
po come il discorso delle macchine ma
questo può più spirituale oggi vi dico
in cosa crede file jpg e credi in dio
jackson e pensi che si domanda
incredibile viene posta ogni giorno
allora io credo che esista qualcosa ma
sono un agnostico ok però non pre non
vado in chiesa non prego il mio modo di
pregare un po diverso in modo di pregare
e io mi immagino un dio che magari non è
quello che ci rappresentano un dio
che se esistesse l'unica cosa che
vorrebbe
secondo me sarebbe guarda che quella
persona che ho creato ha avuto un senso
ok quindi come vivo la mia vita vivo la
mia vita cercando di fare il bene del
bene al prossimo io cerco di essere
gentile con le persone cerco di aiutare
ok cerco di trattare gli altri come
vorrei essere trattato io ok questa è
una cosa molto effettivamente religiosa
perché comunque anche nella bibbia si
parla di questa cosa qua però questo è
il mio modo di pregare nel senso se io
ho una possibilità di andare in paradiso
non vedo perché mi debba venire tolta se
io faccio del bene io faccio del bene
non per finire paradiso ma perché mi
piace farlo ok paraculo so che se
effettivamente qualcosa io dessì la vita
qualcuno sa qualcosa quindi io do la
vita a questa essere io che cosa ho
piacere nel vedere che questa essere
vive bene ok non vorrei essere prega
pietro secondi o minchia grazie va a
vincere mai dato la vita sei un grande e
ogni sera fare sta cosa io la penso così
e non sto dicendo che chi lo fa tutti
anzi io sono di famiglia cristiana per
il rispetto io rispetto tutte le
religioni non c'è assolutamente io la
penso si questo mio modo di pensare non
vorrei che una persona un qualcosa che
io creo quindi i poteri magici ok mi
pregasse tutti i giorni ma sarebbe di lì
fai quello che vuoi basta che lo fai con
cognizione che se una persona
gentile fai le cose per bene bassi
questo è il tuo modo di vivere bene e
quindi mi stai già ripagando di quello
che ho fatto bene perfetto se quindi
esiste una figura di dio ma non sai bene
di cosa stiamo parlando fa vj in cosa
credi esattamente adesso arriviamo alla
parte bene io credo nella in una teoria
che poi ho scoperto che ha proprio un
nome ma io non lo sapevo io ero arrivato
a queste conclusioni da solo quindi io
nei miei viaggi interstellari nella mia
testa che mi faccio ogni tanto da sempre
ero arrivato a questa conclusione qua
che secondo me
l'essere umano che allora prestate
attenzione a questa questa visione che
ho io del mondo per far capire più o
meno come la penso io ripeto non deve
essere condivisa e questo è quello che
penso io però per farvi capire io ho
sempre pensato
che l'essere vivente ok quindi io voi
come se noi non fossimo una persona
diversa noi siamo tutti la stessa
persona
che vive in momenti diversi
ok quindi
tutto questo ve la spiego meglio chi è
che decide che voi siete voi perché voi
siete nati nel vostro corpo e non nel
mio non se chiara questa domanda la
domanda un po strana un po siamo sul
filosofico qua è però perché io sono
nato nel mio corpo e non nel tuo perché
il mio essere e diverso dal tuo essere
ma perché
boh queste sono domande che non hanno
ovviamente risposta e se per caso
esistesse un essere solo e noi siamo
tutti lo stesso essere che vive la vita
in momenti diversi
quindi quando io muoio sostanzialmente
posso diventare voi appena nati quindi
io vivo la vostra vita e voi potreste
vivere la mia una volta morti ok perché
voi siamo in noi siamo la stessa persona
quindi noi quando usciamo di casa
incontriamo un passante tutti tutte le
persone che noi incontriamo siamo noi
che viviamo la nostra stessa vita che
abbiamo vissuto che ancora dobbiamo
vivere nel corpo di un'altra persona
quindi noi siamo un essere unico in
tante persone questo è quello che io
credo e non sto scherzando io credo in
questa cosa che è un po una sorta di è
come se credessi nella reincarnazione sì
ma non è la reincarnazione che io mi
reincarna in una nuova persona che non
era mai esistita no io anche nelle poi
anche internet in una persona che
vissuta nel 1200 se questa cosa fosse
vera tra l'altro vivremo tutti un sacco
meglio secondo me perché tratteremo bene
il prossimo sapendo che siamo noi che
quindi se tu fai il torto a qualcuno
prima o poi titolo ritorna nel senso che
colori vivi proprio ok se non te lo sei
già vissuto quindi secondo me
questa questione qua e un po
cioè io l'ho sempre pensata per i cazzi
miei cioè non è che qualcuno me l'ha
detta sempre pensato che noi siamo
talmente
poco vicini a sapere delle risposte su
che cos'è l'esistenza che siamo un po
paragonabili a una formica davanti a un
computer io metto una formica davanti a
un computer ok davanti a un codice di
programmazione di coda forni katia
programma la formica non sa un cazzo non
sarà che cos'è un computer ok è anni
luce dal computer noi siamo lontani anni
luce dalle dalle risposte proprio come
la formica lo è dal computer
anzi forse noi siamo ancora più lontani
dalle risposte rispetto a quanto è
lontano una formica dal computer è molto
più facile che una formica inizia a
programmare che noi ad avere risposte
questo è quello che io penso che i delle
risposte di tutto del cosmo
dell'esistenza di questa di questo
argomento qua quindi questo cosa vuol
dire questo vuol dire che noi non
sappiamo niente né non possiamo
pretendere di sapere niente perché siamo
totalmente lontani dalle risposte da non
poter pretendere di sapere le cose
realmente come stanno quindi vale tutto
vale qualsiasi cosa perché non sappiamo
niente quindi potrebbe essere questa
cosa che ho detto che come potrebbe
essere che esiste dio potrebbe essere
che esiste che non esiste più potrebbe
essere tutto ma è la verità che noi non
sappiamo questa teoria che ho detto io
quindi siamo noi siamo la stessa persona
che vive nel corpo di un altro in tempi
diversi perché il tempo come sapete se
lo sapete non lo so è comunque una
grandezza che
non conosciamo per bene il tempo non
scorre uguale nel cosmo diversi punti di
dove noi ci collochiamo il tempo scorre
diversamente questo non lo so se lo
sapete se non guardatevi interstellar
che un bello spiega in maniera un po
semplicistica e quindi il tempo come
dicono in interstellar potrebbe essere
per alcuni
esseri viventi nello spazio una gran una
montagna da scalare ok una sorta di cosa
più semplice di come la vediamo noi se
mandando un botto off topic per ora per
farvi capire che comunque la scienza sta
cercando di dare un sacco di risposte a
tante cose
quindi io io sono rimasto affascinato da
tutte queste cose qua
guardando inter stella al tra l'altro
approfondito con questi argomenti
comunque tornando sul discorso quella
teoria che ho io che vivo sulla sorta di
noi siamo tutti lo stesso essere vivente
in momenti diversi ok questa teoria del
giorno io scopro
che esiste e che ha un nome e si chiama
la teoria del luogo ok scavatori a
dell'oro non so perché nel quale tu vivi
sempre
in un corpo diverso tutto il suo ciclo
di vita finché non muori e 6 un'altra
persona affinché non passi nel corpo di
tutte le persone e non ti e levi a quel
punto a divinità questo è quello che la
teoria del nuovo dovrebbe essere se lo
compresa appieno che comunque rispecchia
mostruosamente quella che era la mia
quella che è la mia idea e ve la lascio
anche in descrizione ragazzi perché c'è
un video che spiega bene la teoria del
luogo e quante descrizione è un video
animato e bellissimo suo nome è
veramente bello e appena me l'hanno
fatto vedere dei miei amici con i quali
con i quali non parlato di questo disco
ha detto ama la tua teoria è molto
simile a quella dell'uovo e vi dico di
cosa scusa cosa ne pensate voi ragazzi
fatemi sapere con un commento qua sotto
rischiate canalis e video è piaciuto
come sempre cercherò di avere un po di
dibattito con le cose sono molto curioso
di sapere le vostre risposte io ci tengo
molto a sé discorsi iscrivetevi al bie
rischi sì al video madoff accenti sti
discorsi incredibile non so parlare
italiano fantastico giuliano proseguito
ragazzi un bacino ciao
[Musica]